Justin Bieber has got something to say  and he wants you to hear it what do you  mean the 22 year old is on tour in the  UK right now and had a recent stop in  Birmingham England he got a little  frustrated with the audience Biebs it  took a second out of his set to ask them  to stop screaming while he talks quote  take a chill pill for a second and just  listen to me speak I don't feel like I'm  being a heard sometimes and it's real  frustrating of course Bieber's little  speech was met with what else  screams and some booze if he ever needs  a break from those screams or thinking  cruza Beckham a good step in we already  know David and Victoria son can sing  like Bieber but now he's looking like  him too Victoria shared this pic of her  kiddo rocking summat Bieber inspired a  threads